[Musique]
bonjour je suis jean claude coindin en
fait je suis patron de plusieurs
entreprises notamment cases créoles
construction une entreprise qui a déjà
22 ans
ensuite pas mal de métier encore à côté
comme le bien-être par exemple validé à
notre créole la gestion immobilière et
surtout la télévision
en fait tout a commencé il ya quelques
années de cela parce que mon père est un
marin pêcheur j'ai décidé de pêcher avec
lui mais habré l'école m'a rattrapé donc
j'ai passé mon bac ici à la réunion avec
des études d'ingénieur je suis retourné
ici à la réunion j'ai travaillé dans des
grosses sociétés comme beaucoup de
travaux ingénieurs béton armé et ensuite
j'ai créé cases créoles construction en
1998 et les autres métiers ont suivi un
petit peu après j'ai été pendant
quelques années pilote d'avion donc je
faisais la ligne réunion maurice et
réunion madagascar hinault tromelin
aussi ce que j'ai fait quelquefois la
relève des métiers au lieu d'être on a
quinze pôles construction était un
concept des packs qui a été définie par
un besoin puisque il y avait personne
qui ici à la réunion pour ce musée de
maisons créoles sinon c'était des
maisons créoles qui était très très très
cher donc on a décidé de créer des
maisons qui sont pas cher du tout et
donc des maisons qui sont à la portée de
tout le monde
on était récompensé en 2010 par pas une
médaille qui s'appelle la médaille du
sénat ont été médaillés du sénat pour
avoir construit la maison la moins chère
de france
une maison très simple basé sur un
concept dimensionnelle c'est à dire
qu'on a beaucoup d'émotion et donc on a
fait en sorte de ces d'industrialiser
ses dimensions là pour descendre les
coûts et aujourd'hui on arrive à
construire un peu plus d'une centaine de
maisons tous les ans comme ça
la télépathie d'un principe ou avant je
dépense énormément d'argent à
communiquer pour nos maisons sur
d'autres chaînes de télé à la réunion
aurait donc du coup je me suis dit qu'en
kanal austral était en vente en 2008
pourquoi pas acheter une chaîne de télé
directement tant qu'à faire
de fil en aiguille c'est pas devenu
seulement le chêne faut faire ma propre
communication mais aussi pour m'amuser
et depuis 2008 on arrivait à avoir un
programme qui satisfait énormément les
créoles et aussi la population de
l'océan z
en fait moi j'ai une particularité c'est
que je suis persévérant donc c'est à
dire que lorsqu'on entreprend quelque
chose eh bien je ne lâche pas donc on a
pas fini
celle de faire en sorte qu'on a des
maisons qui deviendront moins cher oui
c'est possible encore de gratter encore
quelques euros puisque aujourd'hui la
technologie nous permet d'avoir des
matières premières qui sont à moindre
coût donc actuellement au travail sur
des modèles de maisons des concepts de
maisons pour descendre encore le prix de
revient